you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar overview of the new er 8
guidelines changes and revisions
presented by dr. Fong
regulatory affairs scientist Smithers
I'm Christie jewel of glaber's and I'll
be moderating today's webinar today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laborat and sponsored by Smithers for
more information on our sponsor please
visit Smithers com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation we will also
be contesting if you pull throughout and
we appreciate your participation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can let us
know you're having a problem by using
the ask a question box this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit i'd now
like to present today's speaker dr. Eric
Phan dr. Vaughn is a regulatory
scientist with particular experience
environmental fate modeling and
regulatory affairs dr. Vaughn has spent
14 years working in academia industry
and at European contract research
organizations and regulatory
consultancies for complete biography and
dr. Thawne please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen now before
I pass this over to dr. Fong let's take
our first pool what is your current
experience of environmental risk
assessment pharmaceuticals
new to you is this an indirect
experience a direct experience or which
some people call you an industry expert
please check one and we thank you for
your participation dr. fun you may now
begin your presentation
thank you very much Christy and I want
to welcome everybody who decided to join
us this afternoon my name is Eric Foner
as Christy just presented I want to
inform you that this is going to be some
sort of a high-level webinar where we
try as much as possible to provide
information on what changes are taking
place in the guidance and how these
changes will affect marketing
authorization going forward I also want
to encourage you to submit questions at
the end we have we have a Q&A session
and we'll try to take as many questions
as possible
so the current version of the European
Medicines Agency guidance on
environmental risk assessment was was
finalized in 2006 but I want to just go
through a historical perspective of what
has changed over over the years in the
European Union's for the European
Economic Community started regulating
medicine since 1965 the previous
guidelines or guidance that were
available at that time have gone through
a number of changes which has culminated
this new version we have today most
notably is during the 90s where we have
had a draft for environmental assessment
of non GMO products in 2006 there was a
drive draft guideline that was finalized
by the Committee on human medicinal
products and this guidance was signed
into law 2006 there were discussion it
was a fest guidance as such so things
were not clear discussions were held at
the European level there was no
agreement a QA document was instead
releasing in 2011 which was updated in
in 2016 so we can see that it's been a
long road and this is this road is we
are still on that route a new guidance
is now available in Prague Beijing
so just looking back at what we have
today as the guidance what is available
today we can see how the tiered approach
for environmental risk assessment of
medicine up for the works in the
European Union however I have a scheme
in for a on your on the screen side at
the moment so I'll just take it from the
top left going towards the right I mean
into this risk assessment what we are
interested in is to look at the exposure
the basic exposure concentration which
is tied to date daily dose of the
measurement is not product and we look
at the toxicology or the mode of action
if we can calculate it exposure
concentration that is greater than 0.01
micrograms per liter which is the cutoff
for the EU if that concentration is
greater than 0.01 the studies in the
middle big box are triggered these are
environmental fate studies eco
toxicology studies and physical
chemistry studies the data generated
from those studies are used to perform a
risk assessment and at the end of that
process if we we could conclude that
there are no no risk or all all
compartments are resolved then the
resource and engel goes ahead we prepare
expert report and conclude that those
stories however if based on the data
that is generated at that phase - most
especially from the OECD one not sixty
which is the adsorption desorption story
if the absorption constant is greater
than 10,000 it triggers a phase 2 TB and
the studies that performed on k2 b are
dependent on the results of of the GA
study there is one other thing to look
at the partition coefficient of the draw
if the kW which is the optimal water
partition coefficient is greater than
4.5 that tree does it
DBT assessment as you have to assess the
persistence
bioaccumulation and the toxicity how
that assessment is done is today not
covered in the in DMR guidance we have
to refer to to reach
the European Union chemical legislation
it and x7 gives a very Bey an
authoritative and complete guidance on
how a PBG assessment should be performed
secondly if there are indications this
drug is not designed to affect
reproduction then there are indications
of reproductive toxicity then we have to
look at the endocrine mode of action and
make an evaluation and conclusion and
perhaps recommend other studies that
that will address the endocrine concerns
and most basically if the exposure
concentration is below naught point
naught 1 and there are no other concerns
then the assessment can stop at that
level so we can see that the flowchart
is just a clean skin starting with the
exposure looking at the intrinsic
properties the physical chemistry
properties and then making it a
conclusion this is the current guidance
we have at the moment
come to the new guidance this guidance
was published on the European Medicines
website on 15 of November 2018 there was
a consultation period which is part of
European law before a new guidance is
finalized it's open for the public
whether scientists interested parties
and the pharmaceutical industry to
comment on it on the on the terms of the
guidance this ended on 30th of June I
hope a lot of you submitted comments or
questions for clarifications these
comments are now been reviewed so to
speak by the Committee on human
medicinal products at the end of the
process a new guidance will be finalized
it will replace the current guidance
from from 2006 the current guidance
still offers the same leg our basis is
drawn from from from the same directives
so the legal basis stays the same and
the current guidance compared to the new
guidance when compared to the current
guidance now opposite a clear decision
tree a step wise procedure on how the
risk assessment will be done going
forward
if we look at the scope of the Lego
basis as I mentioned the legal basis is
the Article III of directive 2001 83
which clearly states that an
environmental risk assessment is
required for all new marketing
authorization applications type 2
variations without major changes for
extension applications you may have to
make a judgement is there a potential
increase in exposure if the answer is
yes then you need a risk assessment for
type 1 variations which are variations
that doesn't affect the safety or
efficacy of the drug you may not submit
a new application or a new risk
assessment this may be a change in the
address of the authorization holder so
minor changes for type 1 be variations
which are you you have to inform the
agency before doing those sort of
changes that generally they do not
affect the exposure so a new
environmental risk assessment is not
required the new guidance handles the
issue with generics today you can
cross-reference to the dossier but going
forward that cross-reference should be
accompanied by a letter of access from
the originator of that drug with consent
to say you can refer to that data the
new besides just touches on
pharmaceutical but we're on drug
products that have radio chemicals
between them these days additional
guidance from the Europe a euro at-home
agency that guidance is still in place
however sudden issues may be handled on
that under the new proposed guidance so
that is just a brief description of how
this guidance came from me from the
historical perspective to where we are
with the update of the guidance in 2018
so I'll just pass you over to Chrissie
to read the seconds of equation please
yes thank you dr. Fong now our next
question for our audience are you
expecting to be involved with the
environmental risk assessment of
pharmaceuticals are you currently in the
middle of one
in the next 12 months greater than 12
months time or no you will not be
involved thanks for your participation
please check one and I will pass it back
over to dr. Khan
thank you very much Christine
not spending a couple of look at a
couple of slides that explain what what
has changing in the new guidance then
the first notable change compared to the
2006 guidance is that there is a
decision tree which specify on which
gives a very good summary on when you
need to do a risk assessment this
decision tree has two points where you
move to the tree if one of the answer is
yes you go for that if the answer is no
then you may stop at that point
so that's the first change that we can
see just looking at the new guidance
secondly looking at the studies but but
that are required eg for physical
chemistry there is more studies now
recommended in the new guidance third
the sediment risk assessment I think in
one of the slides I showed where we had
studies that are performed at phase two
G a the sediment risk assessment study
was not in that on that miss in the new
guidance going forward that study is
required upfront outcome to why why
that's the case on the other hand the
new guidance be one of the longest and
most extensive study that is currently
performed with sediment water aerobics
for uses we see 308 is no longer
required upfront this study may be
performed on the setting conditions that
we'll discuss a further down down the
presentation but this study is now not a
mandated study new change as well is
that new guidance has introduced trigger
values for ground water soil and
secondary poisoning groundwater
assessment was was performed in the in
Dakini current guidance just looking at
the KOC of the drug substance but now
the second figure values the soil
assessment is no longer a TA to be as we
saw in the flow scheme that I presented
and secondary poisoning was not even
mentioned in current 2006 guidance so
these are multiple changes looking at
individual studies we now have it the f1
without a reproduction study which is
now included instead of the
acutally in the 2006 guidance there are
technical details clarifications on on
studies new guidance mentions better
development how some of the studies can
be performed which clarifies some of the
issues that were recognized in inacol
guidance and there is a new section that
deals with antibiotics endocrine active
substances substances that are
persistent by elimination and toxic and
as where they be secondary poisoning
so I have just taken this directly from
from from the new guidance just to show
how that decision tree looks like it's a
series of questions if we just start
from the top the first thing to look at
is that you need to do an environmental
assessment for for for environmentally
relevant compound we can say up front
that biological molecules carbohydrates
proteins and not you don't need to
perform a risk assessment upfront it
this proteins are not modified and then
go into the second branch of that tree
you can either go through the root of
the risk assessment there it's based
solely on the daily dose of the drug and
as I said the cutoff is two milligrams
any drug that is administered at 2
milligrams per liters a PD so it
requires a risk assessment in principle
on the right-hand side of the flow
scheme we have a DVT assessment this is
based on the intrinsic property of the
drug substance we are now looking at the
partition coefficient so those two
aspects now form the phase one
assessment the risk assessment based on
the drug daily dose and the PBT
assessment based of the local W we move
down the tree the next question is the
decision tree including Peck surface
water so if you look at the boxes on
that you need to determine the exposure
concentration which based on the a on
two milligram the mid will give you in
exposure concentration greater than 0.01
if that exposure concentration is less
than 0.01 no further assessment is
necessary so you we move from one
section to the other answering the
questions and providing the answers and
the report that is prepared and we
reflect how this questions were answered
I'm not going to go through all the
sections of the the flow scheme but in
I'll discuss them in in subsequent
slides
and maybe if we blow up the if it's one
of the phase one part I just mentioned
the decision tree regarding limit based
on two milligrams per liter and the
sections under D you have a four point
one four point three these are the
sections where further clarifications
are offered in the new guidance
regarding that aspect so if you want to
read more about PBT screening if you go
to section 5.1 in the new guidance it
deals with PBT screening
so if we take our decision tree for
phase one the question one is is the
active substance in naturally occurring
substance if the answer is yes now we
are looking at things like proteins
we're looking at maybe carbohydrate any
naturally occurring substance because
the assumption is that the amount of
that sort of already present in the
environment is not going to be affected
by by by using that drug so there is not
going to be changing environmental
concentration the next question is does
this application refer to an extent a
article ten of directive 2001 article
ten just looks at what sort of
application you are looking at is it is
it a new application for a new active
substance is it going through the
central procedure to the European
Medicines Agency or is it going through
it it is a decentralized procedure and
send it to to to a member state
Christian to be is now the crucial one
does the applicant have access to an
earlier era this is important for for
companies dealing with generics if the
answer is yes it means you have to you
don't only have access to that data you
have access to the report as well this
means you must have contacted the
originator side agreed on the only
letter of access that will be submitted
together with with with your risk
assessment the next question is was a
default marketing market penetration
factor using the risk assessment now
this is why we have to be careful in
some risk assessments for some reason
you may want to refine the marketing
penetration factor just to go one step
back the default value for the F pain
the market penetration factor is 0.01 or
one percent of the population the agency
assumes that one percent of the
population is using that drug at the
same time for some reason you may go in
and say this drug is meant for less than
other 10,000 people in the e so you can
work out what that percentage is if you
did that and there is a generic or the
another drug that uses that active
substance then you have to be careful
how you refine your exposure
concentration which is taken up and in
the next case on to D is there an
increasing environmental exposure an
increasing environmental exposure in
fear we may occur if a draw if you
expand the patient population if you're
the first marketing authorization
application this drug was used only by a
proportion of the population just
pediatric population for example and
then you want to extend to cover adults
then in principle there is an increase
in exposure which means you need to do a
new risk assessment that doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to do a
new study just means you need to
recalculate your risk ratios and prepare
a new report so we can walk through
these questions at setting points once
the answer is you know then we can stop
and we can prepare the risk assessment
so if we go to the last question that
question seven but the active substance
have a specific toxicity profile this
will cover in general things like
endocrine active substances or
antimicrobials if there is that specific
a specific toxicity profile that means
the decision tree will need certain
modifications for an endocrine drug if
the daily dose is less than two but we
have that toxicity profile that doesn't
necessarily stop the assessment it just
means you have to tailor the assessment
because of that toxicity profile
look to the next slide so if we look at
the phase two for any new guideline to
say phase two is required when the
exposure concentration which is the APCD
predicted environmental concentration in
surface water is greater than 0.01 once
that is established and I can you can
upfront establish that just by looking
at the daily dose of two milligrams then
you need to do a surface water
assessment a sediment assessment and a
sewage treatment plant however if we are
looking at specific toxicity profiles
things like endocrine active substances
or antiparasitics irrespective of the
PEC surface water value if it if the
reduces below 2 which implies the pieces
below naught point naught 1 you still
need to do a phase 2 evaluation because
of that specific toxicity profile then
for certain compartments you only need
to do an assessment if setting figures
are met
this includes a soil assessment a ground
water assessment and secondary poison
assessment where we are going to look at
this figures in in the next slide
so if we sorry I skip once like that
yeah
so let's look at the trigger values for
sport for soil assessment and
groundwater in the current guidance from
2006
we go to face to be just looking at the
slot the absorption constant for sludge
this is derived from a oacd to a 106
study and the cutoff value is just
10,000 if the chaos is large is greater
than 10,000 we automatically trigger a
phase to be assessment now how has this
change if we look at the guidance it has
now included new users now including
looking at the TOC and the predicted
environmental concentration because and
there is a reason for this
in most cases you find you have drugs
that are these drugs that are
administered on very high doses a
thousand milligrams so to speak today
and drugs are admitted low doses just
below 50 milligrams if a drug is
admitted a thousand milligrams and the
KOC is below 10,000 then in principle
you will not need to do if he's to be
assessment while a drug that is
administered at you know 50 milligrams
and has a hike you'll see you need to do
a fifth lesson now there is that issue
of you have a very high exposure from
that high dose which is not up it is
it's not taking account of when we look
at the current guidance that's why the
the new guidance now has this issue of
we look at the exposure concentration if
the chaos is greater than 10,000
irrespective of the exposure
concentration you need to do a soil
assessment
trigger is if the KOC is between 5,000
and 10,000 now you need to look at the
exposure concentration as well if it's
greater than one micrograms per liter
then you need to do if soil assessment
as well and going down you have 1,000
cycles is between 1000 and 2500 then the
cutoff for the exposure concentration is
3 micrograms per liter just looking at
this table it just means a lot of drug
substances going forward we need a fist
in the assessment just just just looking
at that in many cases the kills you lie
between a thousand and about five
thousand and the pdpc will be in that
range of two to three so most of them
which are assessed after this new
guidance is finalized we'll need a face
to be assessment and if we look at the
trigger for groundwater today the
trigger is still is still a matter of
the of the koc ten thousand a
the substances biodegradable we have an
OECD 301 which tells all that
information but in most cases from asada
graphs are not degradable so we still
need to do that groundwater is
assessment
nextslide yeah
so we go to secondary poison which is
one of the new things in the new
guidance
secondary poisoning is just
uptake of a toxic substance through an
indirect route just a crude definition
if we take an aquatic organism fish for
example the fish is in water that has a
certain concentration of a toxic
substance away from a silica active
ingredient this fish can respire this to
the gills and this optic to respiration
that it direct exposure however this
fish as well
consumes other fish or other aquatic
organisms that have been toxic
substances so there are two ways of
these drugs often going to the fish it
could either be through a direct means
or it could either be twin direct means
that indirect means is what is referred
to as a secondary poisoning in the new
guidance and secondary poisoning comes
to affect or is important if the
partition coefficient is greater than or
equal to three once that happens that
triggers a OCD 305 which is a fish bio
concentration study and after the study
if your bio concentration factor which
is the ratio of the concentration the
exposure concentration and the
concentration in the aquatic organism if
it's greater than a hundred then you
need to do secondary poisoning the
assessment itself doesn't need any new
data being generated you can look at
other sections of the of the drug file
look at the mammalian toxicology data to
get a no effect level to use in that
assessment it should speak and then you
can calculate the pinic that's a
particular effect concentration and you
make the assessment for for secondary
poisoning
if there is no mammalian toxicology data
which which is really really rare cases
because drug substances will have a
mammalian toxicology data then you want
me to do any testing we could use a
theoretical assessment provider using Q
some order to determine a Pinnick
the next new Pinder has been introducing
a new guidance is the term endocrine
active substance endocrine active
substances recover drugs that have a
specific mode of action it may be drugs
are at design to affect reproductive
organs or designed to affect
reproductive processes those drugs will
be the end of green active drug there
are other drugs that by design we're not
never intended to affect reproductive
organs or reproductive processes they
will fall on that this category and this
drug will require to theoretical
assessment you have to assess the
endocrine mode of action a risk
assessment based on that and you have to
assess the drug as a chemical entity as
well the second item is the
antimicrobial mode of action here the
action limit as I as I explained
previously does not apply irrespective
of the action dddd me if you have an
antimicrobial mode of action or an
endocrine disruption
you need to do a fish to a assessment
and for these drugs and the
environmental feed studies all
environmental studies are required you
may kill all your effects studies
meaningful for a normal chemical entity
you need to do a fish any life stage
study however if you have an endocrine
mode of action then you need to do a
chronic study of plotting long-term
study which would be the May data
extended generation the fish alien life
stage now becomes redundant it's not
it's not important and looking at order
directly that looks at a protection of
animals in animal a in brain research
you will be able to do both studies so
that's what is called it a lot then you
look at the properties of the active
substance until all the testing to
address those specific issues for soil
and sediment there is no way to Trello
you have to do the studies that are
recommended
for endocrine active substance said this
is a new term that is introducing in the
new guideline this active substance is
the target endocrine organs just to
recap we have to review we have to look
at other sections of the drug in vitro
and in vivo for a review for of the drug
the data we generated we follow a bit of
evidence to tailor the testing number of
studies are listed in the new Dynel that
can be used they may be short term
studies short term chronic studies or
they may be multi-generation studies
these studies are only performed in most
cases after discretion or recommend
discussion with with the reporter just
to make sure we don't have any a
surprises at the end these are complex
studies and you could generate a whole
number of information that may not be be
necessary for that compound so it is
always important to talk to your
regulator before doing the study and for
tailored assessment as I said you can
tailor the fish studies but if we look
at this picture here on the right of
your screen this is a graph that just to
make sure we're clear this was not
produced by also if you look during the
review of the guidance I think a group
at the thing it was a Danish
Environmental Protection Agency actually
made this assessment where they looked
at a series of species and they try to
calculate sensitivity ratios for
antimicrobials they could see that until
until microbials I mean the presence of
data for fish or from an activated
sludge respiration into the individual
test doesn't really affect the risk
assessment itself that is why in the new
guidance for antimicrobials you don't
need to perform these studies because
they don't play any important role in
indeed the risk assessment the revised
guideline has now clarified this
so for antimicrobials you need to do a
number not just one alga study you need
to do a number of argus studies and you
don't need to do a fish study
so we have we have the studies listed
there on the right that is because this
is a tailored assessment with with hello
this assessment to answer that specific
question now if the active substance has
antimicrobial modeling an antimicrobial
mode of option as well as another mode
of action which is not antimicrobial
then you may still need to do a fifth
study and the activated sludge study
to the next slide
so we are looking now at DBT assessment
missions a series assessment on the
persistence the bioaccumulation and the
toxicity of of yourselves and which is
on which is a have that sort of
assessment when do we test for PB for
PBT the first thing to look at is a
low-key Oh W
if the local W is better and four point
five then that triggers the PBT
screening by the time we make that
assessment we have a local W if this
drug substance is also administered at
greater than two milligrams
by definition the exposure is greater
than 0.01 so you may have already
conducted conducted it may just
environmental faith studies if one of
these studies is a fish stories of fish
any lifecycle study that data is used to
assess toxicity if you have conducted an
OECD 305 that data as well we use to
assess bioaccumulation and if you have
conducted a soil assessment that data is
used to assess the persistence if you
have not conducted those studies then
you need to conduct these studies to
address the PBT a classification of
these active substance so for
persistence the new guidance has a
number of options in the current
guidance each of the 308 but in the new
guidance you could either do the 308
which is the water sedimented 307 which
is a source for the or the 309 which is
just the water study itself so you could
pick and choose depending on this
specific circumstance as I said if it's
soil assessment is already triggered you
need the 307 so by definition that is
the data that you use to perform your
persistence assessment and if you look
at the bioaccumulation once the local W
is greater than 4.5 by definition is
greater than 3 so you may have conducted
by concentration study as well that data
comes into assessment of bioaccumulation
and the toxicity if you have not if you
are looking at a situation where you
haven't performed a fish study d OE CT
210 you could see use you are gay
because this as I said this is a hazard
assessment the assessment is described
in rich and x7 it says when you could
classify substances as persistent
substance looking at the half life
better than 40 days by accumulation
currently stands at 2008 D DCF is
greater than 2000 then the drug
substance takes a bad classification now
the new and the old guidance currently
doesn't have any implications where a
drug that is classified as PBT that
hasn't changed in the new guidance there
is no implication process mentioned
somewhere new guidance that you have to
take precautions I mean you may be you
have to review or labeling and and maybe
at some point you have to undergo some
sort of a routine a monitoring just to
make sure concentrations are not higher
than than what was expected if the drug
becomes used by a large amount of and
above the population
on the next slide I think this is just
summary of how the new guidance looks at
a catfish to be to add fish to be in the
old guidance we only look at the
adsorption constant once is greater than
10,000 then we go to face to be that
situation doesn't exist anymore at this
stage
the face to be now depends on adsorption
constant it depends on the exposure
concentration now if you need to do if
is to be assessment for surface water
this is a bit different you have
performed your your your face to a
assess man you look at your exposure
generated is a equal toxicity data and
then your risk ratio is greater than one
as we expose the effect the exposure
concentration is greater than the effect
how do you proceed you can refine your
market penetration factor which is the F
pen you could do that but you need to
generate to to show the agency that you
you have data that is adequate you can
look at the consumption I mean you can
look at metabolic you can look at the
admin section of your blog file and see
whether this drug is metabolized you
have to be careful here if the metabolic
meta meta bellator as well active which
in some cases poor you could find in
drug substances then you may need to ask
yourself what do I assess is in the
active source and/or the metabolite
because when once you perform this this
this refinement based on metabolism you
are opening the door to for that
assessment
you may now end up with two active
substances to to to assess you may also
need to look at the removal in a single
signal plant there is a dedicated model
from from the EU this the STP model
where based on the physical chemical
properties you can calculate how much of
the drug is retaining it in a situation
in plant and how much is emitted into
the receiving water and therefore the
definitive TBT assessment you only need
it when the trigger is made does when
they located the views better than 4.5
for the sediment assessment once you
refine the surface water assessment
since you calculate your sediment
exposure concentration from the water
concentration you can by definition
define your sediment concentration as
well at phase two without generating any
data and then for groundwater you can
refine your pecks you your groundwater
concentration as well it depends on the
surface water concentration so if you
refine your surface water concentration
by definition you refine your surface
water concentration or the new guidance
now has a model developed acting from
the German regulatory agency called
Simba Phi this model you can use to
predict groundwater concentration based
on on the interesting properties of the
drug a substance but that's a new option
that is now available in the new
guidance and if your soil assessment if
you refine your surface water as well
you could refine your soil concentration
and here that's where you have one new
data that you need to do if you need to
refine you just have to extend your your
nitrogen transformation study to 100
days to get the effect data for that
assessment
to detail or assessments
as men for endocrine substances and
substances with its specific mode mode
of action tailored assessment repeat
this it's going to depend on the mode of
action I think we we have seen a lot of
cases where the drugs often that were
not designed to interact with the with
the endocrine system or designed with
endocrine processes or designed to a
vague reproduction we have seen that in
many cases that's why we have the
entrances section of the new guidance
and as I mentioned you could with some
studies with justification but in the
clean drug if the exposure is not above
not by not one then you can actually
wave you the OECD 209 which is the air
activated sludge inhibition test and you
can wave your fish le live stage because
that study does not it's not it's not
sensitive enough for for endocrine
active substances you could check for
every I mean in the studies that are
recommended to check for evidence of it
a effect for intercept for sex we show
what other is feminization this will be
generated in your in your
multi-generational study this data is
generated from that study that is what
is useful for the assessment so we have
just have very high level look at how
this guidance has changed what is
introduced and just to recap it has
introduced a decision tree new triggers
for soil groundwater and instead of a
sediment risk assessment it has moved
some studies from a phase to be up to
phase 2 ETA and introduced secondary
poisoning assessment so on the next
slide I've tried to capture these
changes in in a single slide this this
picture is is similar to the picture on
slide two where we had the current
guidance 88 approach immediately you
could see that this this picture is
expanded compared to the first one if
you start from the top left
we have a decision tree where we run
through this decision tree on till we
get the answer no and then we do our
assessment things to consider is
application status is it a new
application is it for a generic
application is action limit better than
one is a potential for increasing
exposure all those questions we go into
your phase 1 assessment the answers as
well we'll go in there if it's a generic
application then you need to contact the
originator to get a letter of access
that means you and then you look at the
local W if it's greater than 4.5 or
there is an endocrine mode of action or
anti microbial mode of action then you
go to your PBT assessment which is based
on the new ko W or it tailored
assessment which is based only on the
mode of action for tailored assessment
you need always your environmental feed
studies you can adapt your aquatic a
code talks to DS and the sediment of
this story as well is recommended you
can waive that study for your PBT
assessment for persistence you need DD
water sediment study or just the water
on this study or the soils for the year
you can just do one not not both not all
three of them for bioaccumulation you
need to do OECD 305 which is a fish bio
I cooked a concentration study the new
guidance says you could do it in other
species example mussels so if there is a
lab that has experience and doing that
they can actually conduct that study
using using muscles and then for your
toxicity you could look at the CM
intrinsic property classification of the
drug itself or you can look a bit Katoch
studies that have been generated
what is it Noack or the EC 50 and you
can make a judgment on whether that
active substance meets the criteria for
classification if the answer is a drug
can only be classified if it meets all
three it has to be persistent persistent
it has to be bio committed it has to be
toxic then it's a PBT substance but if
you just mix 1 or just 2 of them then
it's not the PBC tivity substance the
report only
if for example if the drug is persistent
that the bio concentration factor is
less than 2000 then you don't need to
test toxicity because it cannot be a PBT
and it's a stepwise study as well you
start with persistence since you don't
need any aquatic species for every
protection of a better base as well in
this edge that's the reason why we start
with the persistence if it's not
persistent then you stop but if it's
very persistent which means VG 50s in
the 120 180 days then you look at the
bio the bioaccumulation if it's not by
alternative just because it's very very
persistent
you still need to label that that bad
drug has a very persistent compound the
second thing to look at from the
decision trees is that concentration
greater than not point not one
if the answer is yes in the first slide
I showed the study we had seven studies
but now we have this number so this has
increased the notable changes the water
solubility study which in some cases was
always performed as part of the
partitioning study is now done as
standalone there is a recommendation to
look at the cessation in water today we
often calculate the association constant
using Q sub models the green fold you
may need to perform that study you may
need to look at the spectra of the of
the active substances this is a new
study that has been included in the
guidance studies that are asterisk you
may choose to do these studies you can
look at melting point vapor pressure as
well I mean for some drugs you the vapor
pressure can be implied and if you say
solid you could assume that the vapor
pressure is going to be quite low so you
don't necessarily need to perform that
study the ko W is normally there you may
have already done it in your face one
because it's using the PBT assessment
the biodegradation you need to do that
study and now the sediment toxicity
study is included in a face to TA
assessment that's a major change in the
new
ion's the reason for this is that most
drug substances will actually partition
to the sediment so there is no reason
why that's what is not done upfront now
we have the alga groups for the other
groups phony witches we have an asterick
and there's no to say tailored studies
may be required for antimicrobials we
have a list of three for studies that
are now in the guidance for
antimicrobials
now after your phase 2 g8 testing then
your face to TA risk assessment will
look at surface water sediment and the
sewage treatment plant you have to ask
the data generated indicate phase 2 a
box will be enough to make that
assessment and then if you look at your
oacd 106 and then we follow the triggers
that I showed him in one of the slides
you come you take that trigger and your
exposure concentration then you
determine the need for the soil
assessment your KOC as well will show
you the need for a ground water
assessment and your locale w will show
you the need for a secondary assessment
if you need to do the phase 2
soil assessment not phase 2b is called
now if phase 2 is soul assessment then
you need to perform nitrogen
transformation study the terrorists are
plants the F form and the coal mbola
and then if your case is less than
10,000 that doesn't need the groundwater
assessment and if you killed W is
greater than 3 that's your secondly
poisoning if at the end of this testing
you can conclude that there is no risk
before that testing is required but if
there is a risk in any of the
compartments then you need to do F is 2
GB now this phase 2 GB is quite
different from more recently current
guidance structure being new guidance it
only deals with refinement you could go
back and ask yourself is that drug
substance metabolize if yes what are
they what percentage is actually
excreted what what amount of the drug is
retained in a symmetry main plant if you
apply all those changes you can modify
your surface water the formula risk
assessment and you make a conclusion if
at the end the risk assessment cannot be
resolved there is no further testing
that is required you have to discuss
this with the reporter and come to some
agreement on how this drug will be
labeled the no further testament is
required so we have seen how the new
guidance mean effect has increased the
number of studies that are required
there is also a section in the new
guidance which actually goes into how
studies are performed for example the
metal development in most cases in the
new dynasty report ever want to see a
report on the metal development as a new
products in current practice the metal
development is integrated with the
ecotoxicity studies by the metal
development now would be a standalone
report that is sent to the agency I'm
going to the chaos video we see the 106
there again there is another Oh a EU
group that is working on on a new
guidance which I think it's already
finalized on how they killed in who
easily 106 should be performin reported
this new guidance refers to that
document on how that study should be
performed so you have to prove to the
agency that if you follow that that
guidance which is not under the control
of of Emma but to prove that that
guidance is followed and you have to
prove that your KOC your your Q a that
you have generated response to all the
the triggers in that document which as I
said is not under the purview of the
agency so that that concludes our look
at how this new guidance has has changed
the testing and the assessment of active
substances so I'll pass it over to
Christopher for for the third survey
question please
thank you dr. Phan for your informative
presentation now let's begin our live
Q&A with our with asking our audience
one last question would you like to
learn more about how the revision of the
guidance could affect your could affect
your marketing authorization application
in the future
I'll ask that question again would you
like to learn more about how the
revision of the guidance could affect
your marketing authorization application
in the future just check yes or no and
we thank you for your participation
today now we have some great questions
coming in for dr. Fong and doesn't
reminder if you do have a question you'd
like to ask and you haven't done so now
is the time to do it just type it in the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and hit Send
dr. thon will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for and those
questions we are unable to answer live
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration okay
that's a--fun yours first thank you very
much thank you very much you see I think
I have just taken a brief look at this
survey I'm certain I see that I mean a
lot of users it's it's quite interesting
that we have a mix it makes group
joining us we're very pleased that we
were able to present this this this
webinar to a very wide audience which is
a quite good for us and I'll take I
think just looking at the questions that
are coming in a lot of interesting
questions I see one here that is are
there changes coming to other regions
eg USA or Canada I think I would like to
take that question I mean thank you for
the question
upfront if we look at Canada Canada has
been revising I mean for the past I
don't know 10 years they have this
discussion on reviewing the how drugs
are there within Canada they have this
system of drugs are considered as new
chemicals in Canada and there is a dual
approach way the Canadian Food and Drug
Administration looks at the safety at
the efficacy and Environment Canada
looks at the environmental as
now this is this is a paper exercise you
have from from Canada you fill in this
information based on the tonnage of the
drug and then the Canadian Environmental
Protection Agency itself would do the
risk assessment however that is going to
change soon how soon is not care so for
Canada we can say there is there are
changes coming for the u.s. the guidance
is from 1998 there are no discussions at
the moment on changes that recently I
mean recently as 2006 there was a new
addition to that guidance to deal with
endocrine egg compounds and I mean
regulation the u.s. system is a bit
different with with how in complexity
with E in going forward and making these
changes at the the u.s. at some point we
follow suit how soon it's unclear at the
moment
X that's one and I see
I see another one regarding endocrine
are there any specific changes with
respect to endocrine testing for
pharmaceutical
I will say yes it's the new dinars
clarifies what studies have to be
performed if you look at the old
guidance oh I think because I can't read
the question secrecy please could you
read read the questions for me
absolutely doctor fine and let's
continue with that question
are there any specific changes with
respect to enter contesting for
pharmaceuticals
thank you very much proceed the new
guidance have just clarified what
studies are required and how that
assessment should be made in the old
guidance
there's nothing about endocrine
substances endocrine sources are only
discussed in the q18 document that is
not the change per se that the new
guidance has just clarify and put
everything on their own that the same
document for authorization holders and
testing laboratories are also to use
thank you very much pretty next question
yes thank you dr. fine
now does the new does the all-new MAA
include middle or large molecule such as
polygon nucleotides or antibodies thank
you very much for that reason Chrissie
it does if we start with antibodies in
general and antibody drug conjugate you
have in most cases a small molecule
attached to to a biologic so that small
molecule is what is covered in this new
guidance that's that's how the new
Gators are purchased in certain aspects
you have to do a tailored assessment and
when it comes to large molecules we have
to follow that phase 1 3 to make sure we
we capture whether a these large
molecule is naturally occurring B if
it's naturally occurring is there any
change to the structure and see is there
is there is there a previous assessment
if we establish that is a naturally
occurring molecule which is a macro
molecule then the risk assessment survey
will be Weaver so to speak thank you
next question fishing
as now the FDA released er a Q&A for
drugs with estrogenic androgenic
activities in 2016 new EU guidelines
cover requirement does the new EU
guidelines cover requirement for FDA QA
and do we need to evaluate these
separately
thanks very much Christopher for that
question the answer is yes and no and
maybe we'll need you can use the same
information to respond to that FDA FDA
2006 Q & A but is that you useful for
the EU the only way is how do you
present the information if we just look
at the e risk assessment system for
human drugs for most drugs only a
categorical exclusion will apply because
they fall under the threshold for a full
assessment in that case that's where
that Q & A guidance comes in you may
need to to address your s tronic or
androgenic mode of action the EU
requires a full assessment now the same
study that is done our recommendation
has always been for sponsors who are in
that position to console with the FDA
and the EU to make sure the studies that
are being proposed and performed allow
them to address both the concerns from
the EU and the concerns from from from
the FDA the way the data is presented is
a bit different that's the only
difference is the same data so and that
difference is just because of how the
assessment is performed in this to the
jurisdiction thank you very much PC
thanks I can find more yes yes
absolutely we have time for a few more
now do we need to measure volcano W at
different pages if a compound is
ionizable
good question thanks PC that's correct
you new guidance recommends and the old
guidance so if you have to be to do to
be frank as well recommends three PS
values 5 7 & 9 2 DB on sighs yes
very good and here's another question
now with regard to androgen active
substances
if a teratogenic compound does not have
any endocrine disrupting potential can
we assume it as nan EAS that's a tricky
one thank you very much yes I mean the
way the guidance is structured at the
moment is that we are looking at
endocrine compounds that affect
reproductive processes that's where this
assessment is going for teratogenic
compounds it mainly to a me if you are
doing a PBT assessment that toxicity you
could get it toxicity level based on on
that
not not the endocrine mode of action you
will not be doing a fish full life-cycle
study to address a teratogenicity so to
speak so that is not covered under the
current guidance we are looking at at
the moment at thinking info for for the
Q&A from from the FDS well they are not
looking at that sort of thing
drug substances although it may present
an extraordinary circumstance you can
address that by other ways not
necessarily by performing chronic fish
studies thanks PC sure thing now I think
we have time for maybe two more quick
ones when do you think the final
guidance for the issue yes I don't know
I mean if we if we just when the
guidance was released in November if we
followed previous approaches we are
looking at the new guidance probably end
of 20 but we there was a result I by the
intelligent assessment from a society
environment they had a conference in
June and and one of the speakers in that
conference actually participating in its
one of the participants in writing this
guidance and because of external issues
I mean most of them the brake seat where
the agency has moved to Amsterdam to a
temporary site and then they have to
move to a permanent site
the agency is concentrating on its core
mission at the moment which is to make
sure drugs are available to look at
safety from ago vigilance as such to got
ad time on this the best guess and this
is just a guesses is not looking like
this guidance will be finalized by the
end of this year so it's an open
question really yeah thank you thank you
dr. Banton we'll end with this final
question are these are these risk
assessments performed just as a check-up
on the environment or if they determine
that a drug is harming the environment
will they change it I'm just confused
about what is done with these risk
assessments
that is very tricky one as well
if we look at I mean just from the US
side the FDA may refuse to file if you
don't have a risk assessment that's
that's a ground for refusing to file for
the for the FDA so it's not just an
exercise I mean it be it has a part to
play some time it's we have to be clear
as well what this actually means a risk
assessment will not prevent a drug
coming to the market that's I mean
that's that's not where we are going
with this
risk assessment will provide the agency
with information on how to regulate this
drug this may be may be telling the
sponsor to perform a toe loop after what
are the drop perform studies to do
routine check today to go out and take
samples and that sort of thing to make
sure there are no effects in the moment
from the European side as well the
agency is clamping down on I mean a risk
assessment is part of the marketing
authorization application so in certain
cases if don't submit a risk assessment
you may depending on how utility of the
drug you may be given a temporary
authorization until you submit a full
risk assessment then you get your
terminal terminal authorization now for
a pharmaceutical company that just adds
a layer of complexity because every time
is disease open reporters have to meet
and there is some financial a cost to
having this done in many steps the short
answer is it's risk assessment is part
of the authorization process and must be
submitted by the terms of the current EU
and an FDA guidance and the second part
of the question deals with is the
information how is the information used
in certain cases some drugs based on the
risk assessment will go into a
monitoring program
that'sthat's it tami food from a sneaker
company that could that could mean a big
financial burden because the regulator
required to go out take samples assess
the sample and then they provide the
result in some cases in 3d we we have
what is called environmentally good
drugs if I could use news that applicant
translated directly in that case they
have a system where if you have two
drugs everything okay everything the
same same therapeutic function that one
of them has a good environmental profile
the Swedish agency recommend that drug
in public procurement also it there are
other ways this information is useful
and the risk assessment is part of the
authorization process by regulation
thank you very much Chrissie thank you
dr. fun and thank you for your time
today and your excellent in presentation
and insight we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Smithers for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and laboratory you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thank you for joining us today and we
hope to see you again soon bye for now
thank you everybody bye